selon la fondation macarthur d'ici 2050
il y aura plus de plastique de poissons
dans les mers du monde
en effet à peine 6% du plastique est
aujourd'hui recyclé quelles sont les
conséquences de notre consommation et de
notre production de déchets déjà pour
fabriquer un produit il faut des
matières premières pétrole métaux sable
en 2013 784 millions de tonnes de
matières premières sont extraites et
transformé dans le monde juste pour la
consommation française c'est
l'équivalent de 78 milles tour eiffel
alors pour économiser les ressources
naturelles
l'idée est de trier mais aujourd'hui
plus d'un français sur deux ne trie pas
systématiquement ses déchets et les
déchets non recyclables
ils atterrissent où une partie d'entre
eux sont utilisées pour produire de
l'énergie à relativiser il représente
moins de 1% de la consommation française
d'énergie finale
la meilleure solution pour préserver
l'environnement et économiser les
ressources semble donc être le recyclage
en france en 2014
il a permis d'éviter le rejet de 6 % des
émissions totales de co2 et d'économiser
250 millions de mètres cubes d'eau
restent à régler le problème du tri
contraintes logistiques manque de
communication pourquoi ce geste est il
pas plus développé en france
[Musique]